public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
public sénat en part
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
président du modem conseiller politique
d' emmanuel macron françois bayrou est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
hier doigt ou et maire de pau bien sûr
je n'oublie pas votre mandat électoral
françois bayrou merci d'être avec nous
ce soir
alors que la campagne du second tour est
désormais évidemment bien engagé vous
répondrai au cours de cette émission à
trois grandes questions que viendront
vous posez jean-francis pécresse de
radio classique et des échos jérémy
marot de la fp et mickaël zeze de public
sénat première question comment
mobiliser face au front national
deuxième question quelle majorité demain
pour gouverner alors qu'au ps et chez
les républicains
certains sont prêts à vous rejoindre
enfin troisième question à quoi
ressembleront les premiers mois de la
présidence et ponctuelle des manuels
macron mais tout de suite une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
est-ce que emmanuel macron a commis une
erreur de jeunesse j'ai envie dire de
deux novices en donnant l'impression
dimanche soir de fêter déjà sa victoire
dans ce contexte où l'on voit le front
national très puissant et un pays
fracturée alors j'entends cette
polémique ou ce semblant de polémique
il est allé boire un pot avec son équipe
et mangé un morceau dans une brasserie
absolument classique parisienne et donc
il n'y a pas la moindre ombre de de
fêter quoi quelques victoires que ce
soit ils ont fait ensemble pris un pot à
la fin du premier tour et deux mois et
de mois de un combat difficile donc
soleil à lima à lille était envoyé est
ce qu'il a été influencé par les
commentaires de fleury sur il a réalisé
le hold up du siècle
l'argent le jeu de coca la moelle à moi
qui lui parle assez souvent je pense
qu'il a tout à fait
la sensation de la gravité de la
situation et du poids de la tâche qui va
être la sienne
et c'est cela qui est pour moi
l'essentiel après quand on quand on
arrive en tête d'une élection alors que
présidentielle alors que c'est la
première fois qu'on se présente aux
suffrages
bien entendu il ya le sentiment qu'on a
réalisé quelque chose qui était pour le
moins inattendu c'est incontestable et
donc on a l'habitude de dire qu'il faut
trente ans pour être devenir président
de la république lui en moins de 12 mois
et il a plus qu'une marche à gravir pour
rentrer à l'elysée
et puis il a fait alors exploser le
système c'est à dire ce que vous vous
attendez depuis 15 ans à prendre la roue
bien ggd et je l'aide dans cette tâche
qui était de salubrité nationale et donc
cette question est très importante elle
est posée comme ça de manière
anecdotique comme si c'était un contour
d'une histoire qu'on raconte mais c'est
pas ça du tout la question la question
ce qu'il ya des moments où les pays ont
besoin d'un bol d'air frais à un moment
où on est tellement au bout de deux de
la lassitude de de l' exaspération à
l'égard de blocage de système qui ne
marche plus qu' il ya des moments où les
pays se tourne vers une vision nouvelle
vers un regard nouveau une recomposition
et pas seulement vers est un homme
nouveau une personnalité un homme
nouvelles jeunes et qui en est fait à
est sortie du cadre qu'on voulait lui
tracé est en tout cas pour moi qui
attend ce moment depuis tellement
longtemps
je considère que c'est un moment clé de
l'histoire conte tels que vraiment vous
avez fait là la fête dimanche soir même
si vous n'étiez pas la rotonde un jeu
n'était pas à la hauteur
j'espère y aller comme j'étais invité
mais je moi je pense que les moments de
joie les plus importants sont les plus
retenus alors c'est un conseil qui
portera peut-être auprès d'emmanuel
macron justement avant de dérouler le
fil de cette émission était trois
questions s'il y avait un conseil
stratégique que vous pourriez vous faire
non vous pourriez nous faire pour genève
et que vous donnez je n'avais rien et et
que vous vous apprêtez à données réelles
que soit demandée marseille que je donne
je puis vous assurer que je ne les donne
pas sur les plateaux de télévision
oui je suis pas le jeu ne vit pas ce
moment comme un moment de moeurs où l'on
s'exprime à la première personne je vis
ce moment comme un moment où des équipes
se forment qui vont avoir la lourde
responsabilité de sortir notre pays de
l'impasse dans laquelle il se trouve
depuis combien 15 ans 20 ans 15 ans et
20 ans qu'on a qu'on vit l'impuissance
publique 15 ans 20 ans que
l'exaspération monte et il va appartenir
à cette équipe nouvelle de d'extraire le
l'énergie du pays pour qu'ils deviennent
rayonnait obtenir des résultats et c'est
un sacré défi pour effet sacré défi
celui celle qui entrera à l'elysée tout
de suite la première question posée
désormais par jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
bon ça c'est michel bonsoir françois
bayrou elle reçoit fusillèrent on voit
marine le pen qui tente de mobiliser
contre emmanuel macron comment comptez
vous vous y prendre pour mobilisez-vous
contre marine le pen
il n'y a rien de plus simple il suffit
de dire la vérité et vous connaissez la
la vérité je veux dire que
professionnellement vous êtes
spécialiste économique
vous savez une chose c'est que si on
suivait et je parle pas de vos opinions
là on est en dehors des opinions si on
suivait les directions que madame le pen
propose on aurait le malheur pour la
france est en france pour les plus
faibles de la france
on aurait le malheur parce que si on
sortait de l'euro pour revenir au franc
la monnaie se casserait la figure et que
donc les retraites par exemple ne
vaudrait plus le montant du chèque le
pouvoir d'achat s'effondrerait on aurait
d'incroyables difficultés budgétaires
par exemple tous ceux qui veulent
emprunter pour construire une maison
pour acheter une voiture pour de
l'électroménager y verrez les taux
d'intérêts explosé et ceci est si
vérifier au travers du monde chaque fois
qu'on a essayé ça que d'une certaine
manière il nous revient à tous comme
citoyen comme spécialiste pour vous
comme citoyen pour moi de dire la vérité
au pays et cette vérité sera
mobilisatrice vous voyez que je jeu par
des propositions sans même évoquer les
arrière pensées qui sont des
arrière-pensées extrêmement dangereuse
de dix vies
lyon des français sur les sujets les
plus explosifs qu'on peut trouver qui
touche à l'origine de d'où viens tu
quelle est ta religion que qui est
ennemie avec qui tout cela comme vous
savez j'ai toute ma vie voulu
réconcilier les français dépassé les
frontières et les antagonismes le
persuader ce peuple qui l'a beaucoup
plus en commun pour se rassembler qu'il
n'a pour se diviser et pour moi en tout
cas c'est un combat de deux de chaque
seconde combat intérieur et combat dans
le débat public question mais marine le
pen elle est laissée depuis hier de
convaincre les français que celui qui va
les appauvrir sait pas elle mais c'est
emmanuel macron et deux au fond montrer
aux atouts l'électorat que le projet
dangereux économiquement c'est pas son
projet c'est le projet des manuels mâcon
messages comme vous savez c c'est de
l'argumentaire politiciens la question
est que mais est ce que vous avez
apporté quand même auprès de ces
français qui sont réfractaires qu'elle a
ses arguments économiques que vous
développez que développe 25 prix nobel
de d'économies que développe ceux qui
font marcher l'économie c'est à dire
tous les patrons mais qui se heurte
quand même à une sorte de mur de
l'incompréhension et jeanne 40% des
français usés mois s'il y avait eu les
votes de marine le pen
je ne crois pas que ce soit les mêmes je
pense que jean luc mélenchon gens je ne
le crois pas vous vous dites oui mais
moi je dis non je pense que jean luc
mélenchon à dimanche soir heurter en
profondeur le
le nombre de ceux qui lui avaient fait
confiance où un grand nombre de ceux
qu'ils aient confiance parce que le au
fond dans ceux qui ont apporté leur
soutien manoeuvre est gros il y avait
l'idée que vraiment c'était le contraire
de l'extrême droite et donc il ya eu là
quelque chose qui a été très je suis sûr
très blessants pour un grand nombre de
gens mais je reviens la question s'il y
a un conte préhension c'est qu'on ne
sait pas expliquer qu'on ne sait pas
parler qu'on ne sait pas convaincre
qu'on ne s'est pas entraîné comment
faire alors c'est pas la stratégique toi
tu es ma question mettait toute votre
énergie et parler aux gens de leur vie
arrêtons les blablas parlons aux gens
dans la célérité que des discours des
manuels m'a conduit en tout beaucoup pas
du tout ce blabla soyez soudan mais
c'est vrai il a été critiqué pour le
manque de vous plaît on est dans un
discours vous écouter mais on est dans
un moment critique où des côtes et moi
on est dans un moment historique
alors dans un moment historique on évite
de se laisser égarer par les par les
péripéties et on regarde l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que aujourd'hui la
france a un choix qui est pour la
première fois depuis des décennies
en tout cas depuis 15 ans ou 20 ans le
choix le plus clair qu'on puisse avoir
d'un côté vous avez le choix de un pays
qui veut vivre et avancer dans la
lucidité et qui accepte tous les défis
qui sont devant lui et qui les relèvent
concrètement pratiquement et puis de
l'autre vous avez des illusions qu'ils
sont mortels
s'il n'est pas vrai qu'on va pouvoir
remettre la retraite à 60 ans il n'est
pas vrai qu'on va pouvoir augmenter le
smic de 30 % il n'est pas vrai qu'on va
pouvoir multiplier les embauches de tous
côtés il n'est pas vrai que l'argent
sera disponible et qu'on pourra tirer
des chèques sur je ne sais quelle banque
donc centrale centrale ou banque
nationale reconstituer tout est faux
dans cette affaire tout est mensonge et
de je suis sûr que le le sentiment
profond des français va le voir et donc
je refuse de me laisser égarer dans
quelques péripéties que ce soit je vais
droit au but et je dis ce qu'est le
risque et de quelle manière il faut
l'affronter
le risque qu'est ce que c'est que si
marine je n'ai été lieu la france mais
les épargnants ceux qui travaillent
aussi court à la faillite mais c'est pas
c'est pas seulement ça c'est d'abord
marine le pen ne sera pas élu
excusez-moi emparé du maillot jaune
alors je ne veux pas accréditer une
telle hypothèse je veux qu'on parte du
fond et du du plus important de l'avenir
de la vie du pays et donc le plus
important de l'avenir de la vie du pays
c'est que si on déstabilise est notre
notre économie nos finances publiques
l'état
si on sortait de l'europe de l'union
européenne et de l'euro alors la france
connaîtrait le moment le plus difficile
et le plus chaotique de son histoire et
elle ne le connaîtraient pas
théoriquement au sens des idées tout ça
naturellement existent mais elles le
connaîtrai dans la vie quotidienne
spécialement la vie quotidienne de ceux
qui ont moins
vous avez parce que ce sont ceux là qui
seraient les victimes
vous avez évoqué la prise de position
enfin qu'il n'avait pas une 1 pour le
stand de jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon écouter les appels du pied du
directeur de campagne de marine le pen
david rachline qui était sur public
sénat ce matin quand il ya des personnes
qui ont voté pour monsieur mélenchon et
qui considèrent que l'union européenne
dans sa forme actuelle prend la mauvaise
direction qui considère que lé recul des
services publics sont inacceptables qui
considère aussi que il est inacceptable
aujourd'hui de faire bénéficier du cic
et les grandes entreprises quand nous
nous préférons idées les petites et les
moyennes entreprises
nos artisans et aux commerçants nous
allons essayer de rassembler le plus
largement possible l'objectif c'est
évidemment d'en porter cette élection
présidentielle sur le projet que vous
et c'est les 144 engagement qui pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux sont
parfaitement compatibles en effet avec
l'ailé les inquiétudes et les envies les
désirs qui sont ceux de certains qui se
sont portés au premier tour sur d'autres
candidats dans une prise de position
publique tout à l'heure le secrétaire
national du pcf pierre laurent a dit
qu'il ne comprenait pas ce silence
insupportable de voir jean luc mélenchon
est ce que vous partagez cette position
d'abord c'est pas avoir de la partager
mais je sais une chose c'est que des
millions d'électeurs qui ont voté pour
jean luc mélenchon ne la comprennent pas
et en sont profondément heurté alors il
ya des idéologues qui qui analyse les
choses
au vu des théories et des des
propositions aussi absurdes les unes que
les autres
excusez moi de le dire pendant que nous
parlons 1 le venezuela
présenté comme un modèle a eu ces
dernières semaines 25 morts tués dans
les manifestations
parce que les produits de première
nécessité ont disparu alors on fait
comme s'il y avait des théories moi pas
moi je regarde la réalité des choses
mais donc est-ce que vous je suis sûr
qu'il ya des millions de gens et
comprennent et a choqué très simplement
que jean luc mélenchon n'est pas appelé
à voter contre marine le pen à moi je
suis et un veau tmap effet j'ai été
stupéfait qu'il ne se prononcent pas
dimanche soir j'aurai j'aurais parié à
peu près de tout ce que j'avais que ça
ne serait pas le cas et comme le disait
matures alors que vous compreniez que
sont blessés tous ceux qui avaient mis
leur confiance ou en tout cas l'immense
majorité de ceux qui avaient mis le
régional recevoir le discours de
monsieur acheter n'avons récolté avec je
n'en crois rien sinon quoi rien je vois
bien les tentatives qui sont pour piper
les voies et pour essayer d'élargir
une base électorale mais je ne crois pas
une seconde que les citoyens femmes et
hommes qui vont se prononcer dans cette
élection se laisse abuser par par ses
discours depuis le premier tour dimanche
on analyse la coexistence de deux france
une france rurale qui rejetteraient la
la mondialisation qui serait plutôt dans
une forme de réaction par rapport à ce
que nous vivons maintenant qu'ils
refuseraient l'europe qui refuse qu'ils
refuseraient le progrès et puis une
france qui serait beaucoup plus ouverte
qui est la france des grandes villes
ouvertes sur l'extérieur sur la
concurrence sur une politique de l'offre
est bien évidemment ouverte sur l'europe
est ce que cette distinction vous la
partagez est ce qu'elle est et répond c
est ce qu il est irréductible
je ne partage pas cette analyse je ne
partage pas cette distinction
il se trouve que la france rurale je la
connais mieux que d'autres
pour ça joue ça venait j ai grandi
j'en viens et je laime il se trouve que
la france urbaine je la connais aussi
mieux que d'autres parce que je suis à
la tête d'une ville qui a toutes ces
caractéristiques là et qui est de ce
point de vue là profondément attachante
je ne partage pas ce sentiment je pense
qu'il ya un problème c'est l'impuissance
publique qui a depuis des années
frappé de paralysie l'action publique en
france
des promesses ont été faites chaque fois
on vous annonce que l'alternance va tout
changer l'alternance entre droite et
gauche
tout cela a débouché sur un sentiment de
un ressenti de scandales de la part des
français parce qu'il voit bien que dans
leur vie rien ne change
alors bien sûr ce qu'ils ont moins de
services publics
ceux qui ont beaucoup de difficultés à
gagner leur vie je pense aux
agriculteurs je pense
aux paysans pour employer le vrai mot
tout cela en effet le ressentent plus
durement que les autres
mais sur le fond il n'est pas vrai qu'il
y ait des france aussi séparé que cela
est ce qui manque c'est des responsables
publics pour entraîner le pays pour
faire partager à l'ensemble des citoyens
l'importance des défis qu'il faut
relever pour que précisément on s'en
sortent tous ensemble dernière qu'elle
est ceci est parfaitement faisable
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez dire d'ici
dimanche 7 mai aux électeurs de droite
hormis le simple fait de leur dire fait
barrage à l'extrême droite qu'est ce que
je voulais qu est ce qu il faut alors je
pense que la question de la france est
en jeu dans cette élection et je pense
que la grandeur de la france la dignité
de la france et l'honneur de la france
et le le lien entre français tout cela
est en jeu dans cette élection
et contrairement à ce que vous croyez
j'espère vous faire partager ce
sentiment
je ne fais pas de différence dans le
discours entre s'adresser à une partie
de l'électorat qu'on appelle de droite
s'adressait à une partie de l'électorat
qu'on appelle de gauche
je pense que tout cela sont des citoyens
français et que tout cela on dans les
douze jours qui viennent maintenant à
mesurer l'importance de leur choix c'est
cette importance là qui moi me mobilise
et qui me et qui me pousse en arriver à
la passion de sept engagés emmanuel
macron s'il est élu contrairement à
jacques chirac en 2002 il aura entendu
l'appel le soutien des électeurs venus
de tout l'échiquier je suis persuadé
persuadé je suis persuadé que oui et
d'ailleurs la démarche politique qu'il a
choisie qui ressemble en effet la
démarche politique que j'ai toujours
essayé de défendre c'est précisément de
ne pas faire de séparation dans ceux qui
ont envie de le suivre ou de lait d
entre eux les camps l'effraction et les
parties alors on va voir justement
comment
le président que vous soutenez qui sera
peut-être et luxueux certainement et lui
enlever certitudes vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure je pourrai jamais employé au
vernet sertic à vous israël sera battu
j'ai une liste et je j'ai une chance à
ces way assez rare rêver d un c'est que
j'ai participé à plusieurs élections
présidentielles et je n'ai jamais dans
ces élections pensé que c'était joué à
la 40 s'accorde accepté facile pas bien
alors le pense pas cela
merci jean francis est donc c'est jérémy
marot de la sp qui nous rejoint
maintenant l'épreuve de vérité avec
bonsoir amis sur michel bonsoir monsieur
bayrou alors vous refusé d'imaginer
l'hypothèse d'une marine le pen qui
accède au pouvoir le 7 mai on se rejette
le 7 mai au soir emmanuel macron est élu
avec qui il gouverne avec quelle
majorité gouverne avec la majorité que
lui donneront les français que lui ont
donné les lui auront donné les français
s'il est élu parce que s'il est élu
c'est que précisément la majorité des
français aura choisi de lui apporté son
suffrage et son soutien ça constitue une
majorité à partir de cette majorité
présidentielle
il va former une majorité législative et
je n'ai pour ma part aucun doute que
comme ils l'ont fait à chaque élection
sans exception les français l'ayant et
du président de la république lui
donnerons les moyens de gouverner et les
parties comment dirais-je qui ne sont
pas au deuxième tour qui ont été écartés
par les citoyens c'est parti là qui
essaye d'expliquer que par l'élection
législative on pourra empêcher le
président de la république de gouverner
se trompent
pour vous les renseignements de risque
de l'évidence et ne le suivront pas la
cohabitation je considère enfin moi je
suis je crois de toutes mes fibres que
les français seront cohérent seront
simplement tireront les conséquences des
choix qu'ils ont fait en donnant au
président de la république élu la
majorité qui lui permettra de gouverner
et ça aura un autre avantage c'est que
cette majorité permettra de renouveler
profondément les visages de la vie
politique française
alors j'ai déjà il faut préparer aussi
les élections législatives on attend
toujours d investiture pour l'instant
seulement 14 tant mieux tant mieux mais
je veux dire le l'idée qu'on pollue ray
ou qu'on troublerait ou qu'on ne
pèserait sur l'élection présidentielle
par la distribution d'investiture pour
des élections législatives qui vont
venir plusieurs semaines après est une
idée baroque
en tout cas moi je considère que c'est
une idée qui qui n'est pas cohérente
tout le monde sait que quand il ya des
investitures ça provoque des sentiments
mitigés chez les uns et chez les autres
chez tous ceux qui pensent ou
souhaiteraient avoir ces investitures
c'est donc pas le moment
en plaine entre les deux tours d'une
élection présidentielle d'annoncer des
investitures législatives en tout cas
tel est mon sentiment pourtant emmanuel
macron l'a annoncé la diffusion reprise
il y aura une vague d'investiture entre
les deux tours s'était dit encore la
semaine dernière moi je vends en
attendent beaucoup peut-être l'at-il dit
mais si j'ai un conseil rappelle pas si
j'ai un conseil à exprimer c'est que il
faut se concentrer sur l'élection
présidentielle faut se concentrer sur la
question qui est posée aux français pour
une fois dans une absolue transparence
que que voulez-vous que soit l'avenir de
notre pays vous avez deux propositions
politiques qui sont en effet deux
propositions politiques qui ne qui ne
disent pas la même chose de la france et
de l'avenir de la france et je n'ai pas
de doute que les français vont se
prononcer de manière absolument clair
qu'ils vont répondre à cette question et
tous les tous les moments de
d'authenticité pour le pays permettent
de répondre à cette question qui est une
question de devis
des citoyens alors nous avons envie de
former un pays rassembler et pas un pays
divisé
nous avons envie de nous respecter et
pas de nous mépriser
nous avons envie bien j'étais ce matin
peut-être vous aussi avez vous suivi aux
obsèques du policier du jeune policier
qui a et nous l'avons suivi je vais en
tous été bouleversés par risque est
entendue j'ai été moi bouleversé par le
discours du compagnon de du jeune
policier tué c'était un discours
magnifique de deet est magnifique de
justesse magnifique de générosité et ce
discours était du côté d'un pays qui se
rassemblent et pas d'un pays qui est qui
qui fait prospérer des divisions et des
ressentiments et pourtant dieu sait que
quand on perd un être cher dans des
circonstances comme celles là il ya
toutes les raisons d'être habité par
cette et bien non c'est le il a donné ce
jeune homme un superbe exemple
en tout cas je les ai entendus comme tel
et tout le monde était bouleversé
quelles que soient les opinions
vous avez vous gardé des larmes dans les
yeux de tous ceux qui étaient là et je
vous jure qu'à cet instant il n'y avait
aucune aucune idée de aucune volonté
d'aller vers ce pays en affrontement où
on voudrait nous entraîner reste il ya
le débat politique et donc vous êtes sûr
qu'il y aura une majorité cohérente pour
emmanuel ma jolie croire s'il est elle
une écoute ont quand même ce que dit par
exemple bruno le maire lui il imagine
quand même
l'hypothèse où aucune majorité claire se
dégage et et il est prêt à une alliance
on écoute s'il n'y a pas de majorité
claire se voudra dire quoi se dire que
les français nous ont dit travailler
ensemble débrouillez-vous ce cas là je
ne me déroberai pas à mes responsables à
dire que vous pourriez travailler avec
emmanuel macron évidemment que je
pourrais travailler avec le prochain
présentés république si celui-ci ses
genoux réserve que les français de
l'affluence décide
oui dans la clarté oui c'est à dire avec
une situation politique clarifier au
lendemain des élections législatives au
10 juin oui alors la main est temps de
vous l'avez vous voyez vous voyez que
tout le monde y vient
vous aviez entendu les débats des
primaires les les anathèmes les
condamnations
et puis vous voyez que devant
l'événement devant la gravité de la
situation
tout le monde à droite et à gauche et au
centre dit mais au fond c'est ce qu'il
faut faire il faudra travailler ensemble
on ne pourra pas faire autrement que de
travailler ensemble et donc vous voyez
que tout ce qu'ils proposeraient aux
français de délire une majorité de
paralysie de l'action du nouveau
président de la république tout cela
sort en rejeter cette c'est un peuple
qui a une grande habitude de cette
cohérence au travers du temps je me
souviens de françois mitterrand qui
disait en 1981 j'étais très jeune
citoyen il visait en 1981 vous
n'imaginez tout de même pas que les
français seront assez stupide pour mes
lire président mais me refuser une
majorité en juin et ceux ci c'est un
argument de bon sens et de
responsabilité et les deux auront leur
rôle
parlant de la droite justement pour
l'instant un seul parlementaire a
rejoint en marche c'est le sénateur jean
baptiste lemoyne la droite reste pour
l'instant groupe et comment ne pas rater
l'ouverture vers la droite et convaincre
ces parlementaires de vous rejoindre et
de gouverner alors quand vous dites que
ce ce parti reste groupé c'est que vous
ne lisez pas les articles que vous
écrivez officiellement il ya une
position commune maintenant il ya des
individualités qui s'exprime par exemple
alain juppé alain juppé dit qu'il faut
orienter la politique de son parti donc
dans une politique humaniste européenne
et là vous vous seriez peut-être le
parfait trait d'union vu votre intimité
avec la ngp en traversant les couloirs
du sénat pour venir à votre émission
j'ai rencontré plusieurs parlementaires
de de l air de l'ump devenu l air et
tous disent aimer c'est pas possible
qu'on ait une position comme ça faut
qu'on dise des choses claires alors je
ne dis pas que c'est l'unanimité
puisqu'il paraît qu'ils se sont divisés
je dis que c'est le sentiment de
responsabilité qui éprouve un grand
nombre de ceux qui sont les cadres et
les animateurs de ce mouvement et il me
semble que dans les heures qui viennent
ou dans les jours qui viennent a
beaucoup de ceux là vont s'exprimer avec
un appel
beaucoup de ceux là vont s'exprimer pour
dire clairement vers qui va leur choix
et que nul ne puisse mettre en cause les
orientations qu'ils vont exprimer ce
maillot on veut s'attacher à la
transparence donnez nous des vous donne
un jeu venir je ne suis par les
associant estrosi je ne sois là vous
voyez vous connaissez beaucoup des
allèges délégation vos contacts avec lui
en ce moment je le dis en quoi ça va
démarrer
je ne me sens pas autorisés à faire des
déclarations à la place de ceux qui en
sont les responsables sauf que vous avez
des contacts directs avec alain juppé je
reviens sur ce sujet et donc chacun
s'exprimera et je ne doute pas de la
force de leur expression
pouvez vous nous dresser le profil idéal
un gouvernement d'ouverture des milliers
de droite des milieux gauches des 1900
je n'ai aucune envie de jouer à ce jeu
je vous demande pardon parce que c'est
un jeu qui vous plairait beaucoup et
peut-être mais vous avez beaucoup de
choses à dire sur les jeunes même à vous
rendez vous retenez la wii jeu j'ai
beaucoup de choses à penser sur le sujet
j'ai écrit des centaines de pages pour
expliquer ce que je croyais ce que je
crois c'est que la grande majorité des
français partagent les mêmes valeurs et
les mêmes orientations pour l'avenir
ce que je crois c'est que la grande
majorité des français par exemple est
attaché à l'idéal européen
la grande majorité est agacé par la
manière dont l'europe fonctionne ou
plutôt ne fonctionne pas à la manière
dont le les les mécaniques de décisions
européennes sont pas assez efficaces et
dissimulé ou en tout cas opaque aux yeux
des citoyens et je partage
l'insatisfaction et je partage l'idéal
et je suis sûr qu autour de cela il y a
une grande majorité de français
vous croyez que les français ne voient
pas que dans le monde dangereux où nous
sommes ceux qui leur proposent de
s'isoler les conduisent à la catastrophe
vous croyez que que quand ils pensent à
leurs enfants ils ignorent ça mais il
n'entend aussi d'air qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment pris en compte la présence
du front national au second tour il a
déclaré aujourd'hui 20 1 françois
hollande bon on est dans une situation
de transition et mais il s'est exprimé
clairement le problème c'est que il
n'aurait pas fallu laisser grandir les
raisons qui ont fait le succès du front
national et ceci jeu limpide pas
françois hollande uniquement jeunes
impute à une longue période dans
laquelle le la la pratique politique n'a
pas donné les résultats que les citoyens
étaient en droit d'attendre une dernière
question permettez moi juste d'un
système et dans les principes her for
pouvait insister ça m'étonnerait que
votre science et raison de mes
résistance en les principes forts qui
ont été édictées par emmanuel macron il
ya celui du pluralisme du renouvellement
on parle par exemple pour les
législatives de 50 % de candidats issus
des zones moins deux villes au moins et
50 % au plus donc
d'élus qui sont ces élus est ce que ce
sont des élus de droite de gauche du
centre on y voit pas très clair pour
l'instant c'est que beaucoup de rallier
de je peux et je sens que je peux vous
dire une chose certaine c'est que le
mouvement démocrate que je préside sera
en tant que tel présent dans cette
majorité nouvellement vous avez un
accord et nous avons d'accord nous avons
une alliance et que je peux vous dire
aussi une chose c'est que les candidats
qui seront présentés n'appartiendront
pas au monde des sortants parce que nous
n'avons pas de sortant ah non non elle
avant the l'électricité fait nous sommes
bien d'élargir son seront évidemment
dans cette série et donc oui pour moi
c'est cet engagement de renouvellement
et cet engagement de pluralisme
c'est ce qui a fait le saut même de
notre alliance toute dernière question
ailleurs cet accord cette alliance que
vous évoquez c'est un peu secret défense
un canton demande combien de
circonscriptions réservées aux élus mais
bien comme ça quand on vous posera la
question vous dirais que vous ne savez
pas c'est le but de la remercie jérémy
émis 15 ms tout de suite nous rejoindre
pour la dernière partie de l'épreuve de
vérité
[Musique]
bonsoir michael st michel ou son
monsieur bayrou bonsoir emmanuel macron
ne crois pas aux 100 premiers jours d'un
président at il tort je comprends très
bien ce qui dit quand il dit que ce
n'est pas son son approche des choses
mais il ya beaucoup de choses qu'il faut
faire dans les 100 premiers jours et des
engagements qu'il a pris
il y en a par exemple c'est que avant
l'élection les élections législatives
il nous poserons il posera sur la table
du conseil des ministres
une loi de moralisation de la vie
publique seniora ce que je dis pas que
ce soit l'urgence je dis que ça on peut
le faire en quelques jours
on peut écrire cette loi avec les
différents aspects qui doivent être les
siens par exemple une guerre sans pitié
contre les conflits d'intérêts où les
soupçons de conflit d'intérêts est ce
qu'on appelle conflit d'intérêts c'est
très simple c'est quand l'intérêt privé
l'emportent sur l'intérêt général que
l'on fait en sorte que la décision
publique
elles soient prises pour au bénéfice
d'intérêts privés 14h06 ans par un homme
politique d'avoir un autre métier comme
avocat interdire à un homme politique
d'être le conseil comme on dit entre
guillemets de deux des sociétés qui
pourraient avoir intérêt à ses choix et
donc ceci se fait dans tous les autres
pays démocratiques d'europe en tout cas
deuxièmement il faut avoir une certitude
que le financement de la politique
devient clair par exemple la politique
est pleine de micro partis comme vous
savez plusieurs centaines qu'est ce que
c'est les micro partis cette la manière
légale de tourner la loi c'est à dire
chacun organise sa petite boutique avec
son propre financement qui échappe à la
loi sur le financement des partis
je considère que ça ne va pas et ainsi
de suite il ya un certain nombre de
châteaux moralisation de la vie
blick est ce que emmanuel macron a dit
c'est que ce serait sur la table du
conseil des ministres avant les
élections le premier déplacement que
ferait le président s'il gagne emmanuel
macron et ce qui ne doit la corde et
angela merkel oui j'imagine qu'il pense
pas autrement
alors ghilat mme merkel à son
gouvernement à ceux qui ont la charge de
diriger le pays qui est notre premier
partenaire notre premier client notre
premier fournisseur et notre premier ami
il ya eu aujourd'hui une mode de la
détestation de l'allemagne moi je pense
que cette mode est néfaste pour la
france parce qu'elle nous et empêche de
voir en face les problèmes qui se posent
à nos deux peuples aux nôtres et à nos
deux peuples ensemble de réconciliation
du couple franco allemand c'est ce que
vous faisiez aliments de réconciliation
de de nouvelles impulsions voilà d'un
nouvel élan de deux peuples qui décide
d'affronter ensemble parce qu'ils sont
voisins les réalités du monde et ainsi
de donner à l'europe
cette nouvelle impulsion qui permettra
de répondre à la critique que les
citoyens et met sur le fonctionnement de
l'union rosario avant le premier tour
avec l'attentât qui est lui à paris on a
beaucoup entendu parler des candidats
qui militait pour une urgence et la
priorité soit mise sur les actions
contre le terrorisme louis que du coup
cette priorité là ne devrait pas passer
avant la loi de moralisation tous les
mois enfin la mobilisation des services
de renseignement et des services de
police elle est entière et vous ne
pouvez pas insinuer le contraire au
moment où nous venons sans les autres
candidats qui longtemps glaner ce qu'il
insinue ne vont pas dans le bon sens ya
même des candidats qui proposait de
désarmer le les policiers ou de désarmer
notre pays moi en tout cas ça n'est pas
mon sentiment
mon sentiment est que la mobilisation
n'est pas une question de quelques
semaines c'est une question de tous les
jours
pendant les cinq années que nous allons
vivre et j'ai exprimé vous m'avez
souvent entendu le dire
l'idée que le suivi de la menace
l'observation fine de la manière dont
évoluent les choses de la part des
terroristes doit être notre guide
c'est nous avons constamment adapter la
défense à la menace la menace évolue la
défense doit évoluer aussi voilà
pourquoi emmanuel macron propose de
réorganiser nos renseignements le
renseignement
mais ce sera une oeuvre de cinq années
là vous m'interrogez sur les progrès
limités à 20 il y aurait alors du mal à
au début il y aura les dossiers
économiques et sociaux et emmanuel
macron annoncé au doute
une nouvelle loi travail il n'a exprimé
d'ailleurs sur public sénat on écoute
une réforme par ordonnance je propose
qu'une concertation accéléré en début de
quinquennat et sur ce sujet là qu'on
fonctionne par ordonnance pour le faire
durant l'été pourquoi parce qu'il a
besoin d'un choc de confiance d'une
vraie accélération d'une détermination à
l'épreuve et parce que nous avons besoin
de faire passer cette réforme pour que
les premiers effets s'en fassent sentir
assez rapidement vous confirmez ce qui
est concertation cancer passé chaque de
force et chef de confiance et ces deux
mots sont deux mots clés avec le risque
de on a vu ce que ça a donné avec la loi
elle conneries non mais demandent
comment faire
l'élection présidentielle va intervenir
l'élection présidentielle donne au
président un mandat l'élection
législative et élections législatives
vont suivre elle donne à la majorité et
au gouvernement un mandat est de ce
point de vue là oui la légitimité est
plus forte que celle des gouvernements
précédents qui avaient qui d'une
certaine manière faisait un peu le
contraire de ce qu'ils avaient dit qu'il
ferait comprenez c'est pas la même chose
d'agir lorsque vous avez un mandat
d'agir en dehors de tout mandat et le
le travail qui lie à faire je vous
rappelle que les ordonnances
elles sont votées à l'assemblée vous
êtes en rentabilisant c'est quelque
chose qui vient d'infliger il ya des
sujets sur lesquels on doit on peut on
doit avancer par ordonnance pour éviter
l'enlisement dans lequel on vit depuis
trop longtemps
l'enlisement ça ressemble aussi à ce
qu'on avoir entendu par le 49-3 ça se
ressemble un petit peu ou pas c'est pas
exactement mon sentiment
moi je pense que le 49-3 a été choquant
parce que le débat n'a pas eu lieu
donc avec des ordonnances le débat aura
lieu donc il ya un débat sur la loi
d'habilitation par ordonnance le
gouvernement vient devant le parlement
et il dit au parlement qu elles vont
être ses orientations et ses choix et le
parlement lui donne cette cette
habilitation
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre dans
l'entre-deux tours vous avez
certainement dû en parler avec emmanuel
macron a peut-être une mesure sorti du
chapeau
concernant les syndicats je déteste le
mot sorti du chapeau ce n'est pas c'est
pas de la prestidigitation
le train qui n'a pas encore été annoncée
la conva préfère va avoir à en effet
expliciter les choix qui sont les siens
certain qu'il a déjà annoncé qu'ils
n'ont pas été entendus
parce que le brouhaha de la campagne
électorale empêcher qu'ils fussent
tentant but et peut-être d'autres qui
l'expriment ça pourrait ressembler à
quoi notamment une plus forte présence
dans les conseils d'administration je ne
sais pas si vous avez compris mais je ne
suis pas le candidat à la présidence de
la république
peut-être il cela commence voulait pas
nous dire vous savez ce conseiller donc
oui en tout cas je parle avec lui je
suis pas je suis pas dans une fonction
de conseiller et de nouvelles lois sur
le marché du travail notamment et
notamment du renforcement des relations
que les scènes cas vous ne risquez pas
les packs crainte d'avoir une rentrée
sociale importante avec des gens dans la
rue et notamment ceux qui ont voté pour
une personne jean luc mélenchon qui
était plutôt dans les contestations et
bien je ne le crois pas vous parlez de
la légitimité mais pour cela il faudrait
qu emmanuel macron obtiennent quel
pourcentage
de voir ce sera pas les 80 % de chirac
n'attendez pas de oui bah les 90 ans de
jacques chirac n'ont pas donné la
légitimité qu'il aurait fallu
précisément parce que jacques chirac a
choisi à l'époque il a écrit depuis
qu'il le regrettait a choisi à l'époque
de au fond de ne pas tenir compte de de
l'importance de la base de ce qu'ils lui
avaient apporté leur confiance
emmanuel macron ne veut pas d'un nouveau
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
et c'est à dire que le dernier budget du
quinquennat de françois hollande est le
bon l'idée que emmanuel macron développe
c'est que en matière de finances
publiques il faut respecter ses
engagements
il ya beaucoup de gens qui rêvait ou
proposés dans cette élection de ne plus
respecter les engagements
moi j'apprécie que ça qu'on dise nous
allons respecter les engagements de la
france
j'ai une petite dernière question plus
personnelle si vous le permettez maire
de pau vous êtes vous resterez après le
7 mai eh bien nous verrons ensemble
comment je peux répondre à deux
impératifs que je vais rappeler devant
vous le premier c'est que je suis
attachée à ma ville et que je resterai
dans cet attachement et que je ferai
tout ce que je peux pour qu'elle se
développe dans le 9ème r est le deuxième
je ferai tout ce que je peux pour que
mon pays ce tir se sortent de la crise
dans laquelle il est
vous voyez que ce sont deux engagements
qui sont contraires complémentaire je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'il ya
le cumul des fonctions
un citoyen de pau il a deux
appartenances y les citoyens de cette
ville formidable et en même temps les
citoyens français et sa vie elle dépend
du développement de la ville et du
redressement du pays
donc dans deux endroits banques
retrouvez tout ce que je pourrai pour
remplir ces deux engagements avec le
même temps qu en même temps et en heure
et en même temps de responsabilité une
d'élus
une au service de l'exécutif eh bien
nous verrons nous verrons verront ces
c'est uniquement le président de la
république et lui qui peut décider de ce
genre de jouer en toute confidence de
vous allez nous dire qu'on n'en avait
pas parlé encore avec lui je n'ai jamais
eu de dernière question vous avez eu un
éclat de rire navette jeu non je
voudrais vous dire une chose et moi très
simple je vous crois il ya des gens qui
racontent des histoires
et moi je vais force de dire la vérité
c'est surprenant sur ce plateau mercadal
tous les gens que vous invitez vous
raconte nicolas sarkozy va
nicolas mas en tout cas quand je vous
dis que je n'en ai pas parlé avec lui
c'est que je n'en ai pas tant la sarkozy
va annoncer qu'ils votent macron sais ce
que c'est ce qu'annonce la fp vous vous
saluer ou le à tanus et laborieux le le
choix responsable c'est celui qu'on
annonce pour ouvrir la sarkozie échos et
que vont prononcer un grand nombre
d'autres responsables du parti les
républicains je n'ai aucun doute qu'ils
vont tous s'extraire de le 2 de cette
ambiguïté pour prononcer le choix
civique que la france attend merci à
vous on va continuer à suivre cette
campagne sur public sénat et demain
d'ailleurs il y aura une nouvelle
épreuve de vérité avec payant philippe
pour le numéro 2 du front national
bonsoir à demain
[Musique]